I not only like to buy a light to buy
and pay off oh interesting yes I know
well I'm very borrowing of it although
we spoke about boring earlier borrowing
for a means I understand
um the loan that started my business was
paid back within two and a half three
years and it was a 20-year loan I like
to pay back loans I like to know what
I've got I like to know what's mine so
my advice on that or my tips would be
don't be a loan avert because money can
make money if you've got access to it
you can make money from it but I would
say on buying property for me your key
property you live in buy it own it get
it paid for it can't be taken away from
you you've got such security for you
your family and your wife for the rest
of your life
foreign